you can't really talk about mortal shell
without talking about its obvious
inspirations
from software's soulsborne games dark
souls bloodborne and sakura shadows die
twice
developer cold symmetry has created a
love letter to from's games with its own
souls-like
and mortal shell borrows liberally from
the soul's control scheme its combat
formula
and its minimalist approach to
storytelling you seem different
untouched mortal shell is more than a
retread however
it adds ideas of its own that shift the
way you think about its combat
introducing a more deliberate and
strategic pace
it sends you down dark forest pathways
into strange twisted temples
guarded by challenging bosses and it
provides a bunch of wispy spooky lore
for you to piece together
as you scour its world for everything
you can discover
mortal shell is a sort of small scale
souls-like game demanding less of an
investment of time and frustration it
feels tuned for people who've been
interested in the soul's experience but
who may be struggled with its difficulty
while still striking all the same
essential nerves
you play a faceless voiceless being
dubbed the foundling
more akin to a spirit or revenant than a
person who ventures into a decaying
poisonous world known as falgrim
there most people you come across want
to murder you and in your undead-ish
form you're not much of a match for them
one hit will destroy you to survive
you'll need a better body which is where
the name mortal shell comes from
you're able to inhabit the corpses or
shells of some tough warriors you find
along the way
which make you a little less prone to
death the four shells in the game
each play a little differently from one
another providing a set of characters
you can swap between
as you play each shell also has unique
special perks you can unlock in a
typically souls-like way by spending
currencies you earn from killing enemies
currencies you permanently lose if you
die and don't retrieve them from your
own corpse
combat in mortal shell owes its basics
to dark souls and bloodborne you have a
fast light attack
and a slower stronger heavy attack as
well as a backstep that you can convert
into a roll to dodge your enemies
how much you can swing your sword and
how many times you can dodge are
dictated by a stamina gauge and there's
a tightly timed parry move that opens
enemies up to a brutal riposte attack
which also heals you
the thing that sets mortal shell apart
from its inspirations is the harden
ability which lets you briefly turn to
stone and tank a hit
before the stone breaks harden has a
short cooldown so you have to use it
strategically against an enemy's attacks
you can also start an attack and harden
midway through
ignoring your opponent's strikes so you
can land your own the harden ability
provides a new set of essential
strategies to mortal shell's combat
hardening lets you turn yourself into a
trojan horse
baiting your enemies to attack you so
you can get in under their guard
especially with tougher bosses the key
to victory is almost
always to harden yourself so you can
score a hit and keep your combos going
when you'd otherwise get eviscerated
harden along with a very forgiving dodge
also subtly lessens mortal shell's
difficulty
and that seems to be the alchemy cold
symmetry is going for
mortal shell feels like a dark souls
game pushing you to build skills
study enemies and carefully dole out
your resources but it's also one with
abilities that give you
extra forgiveness and the game doesn't
expect you to spend hours working on
defeating a single boss
the big drawback of mortal shell's
combat system is that it's easy to
become
too reliant on hardening to slowly chip
away at difficult enemies
instead of finding clever ways to use
harden against bosses and outsmart them
you can fall into that much more boring
strategy turning fights into lengthy
slogs where you never feel like you're
in any real danger
mortal shell's big focus outside of
combat is on exploration
you spend most of your time wandering
through falgrim and its three huge
temples which stand as zelda-like
dungeons
each temple is markedly different from
the others and provides some gorgeous
inventive settings to fight through
including a deep icy cave a flaming
crypt and a twisted
floating obsidian tower the locations
feel specific to the challenges within
and exploring them is a treat as you're
rewarded with lore and weapon upgrades
for checking every corner
exploring falgrim also brings up mortal
shells familiarity system
when you first find an item in the game
you're not told what it does but using
it builds familiarity which can change
or upgrade the item's effects
eat a poison mushroom the first time and
you might feel dumb for making your
character sick
until you max out your familiarity and
gain poison protection from the mushroom
instead the system
rewards you for learning about the world
while giving you a good reason not to
hoard all your items
you'll also delve into the four shells
you find by unlocking their memories as
you upgrade them the memories provide
more tidbits of story and lore for you
to pour over and try to make sense of
giving each shell
a bit of personality in typical souls
fashion however you'll still have to
piece together all that lore
and plot on your own how else could he
know so much about me
he had condemned himself with each
utterance it's in some of this
exploration
that mortal shell stumbles most the
swampy fall grim area that connects the
dungeons
all tends to look the same and it's easy
to get lost trying to find your way to
the next temple to advance
landmarks aren't extremely obvious and
it's all pretty maze-like and i spent a
lot of time
accidentally going in circles trying to
find my way forward
there are also times when enemy
placement can feel frustrating
or cheap mortal shell really likes to
ambush you with combatants you can't see
until they show up
so much so that it's easy to get
overwhelmed at a few points that can
force
you to repeatedly run back through those
big confusing areas which is a drag
still mortal shell succeeds more often
than not at capturing the specific
feelings
intrinsic to souls like games the twist
it adds to frum inspired mechanics do
well to make it more approachable than
most while maintaining that same
air of mystery and foreboding that makes
the genre so intriguing
mortal shell especially makes for a
great introduction to souls likes if
you're new to them demonstrating what so
many players have found so interesting
about this kind of game but mortal shell
is also a lovingly crafted
weird and deceptively deep game in its
own right that rewards you for wandering
its dark pathways
and challenging its deadliest foes
[Music]
you